there are some truly talented actors
backing up Oscar winner brie Larson as
Carol Danvers most of whom you've
probably seen on several occasions
without even knowing it from her allies
and star force to the villains of the
piece he is why you recognize a cast of
Captain Marvel Jemma Chan joins a
Captain Marvel cast as Minerva a Kree
scientist and loyalists
in the comics she was part of a plot to
eliminate 90% of the Kree Empire which
would have forced a remaining 10% to
evolve at a quicker rate Chan turned
down a job with an international law
firm to pursue a career in acting
which began in earnest when she was cast
in the critically acclaimed sci-fi
series humans
she then scored a variety of minor roles
in Hollywood but Tinseltown didn't
really start paying attention to Chan
until 2018 s crazy rich Asians blew up
in the comics Minerva worked closely
with fellow Star Force member Atlas when
he discovered that she wanted to
eradicate the vast majority of their
race he intentionally made his suit
self-destruct taking Minerva with him
Atlas is played by our hennas Paris Soto
a relatively inexperienced actor with
only a few film credits to his name one
of those films was helmed by anna Boden
and ryan fleck co-directors of Captain
Marvel they've known Soto for a long
time having plugged him from above all
drama sugar he fell off the radar
following sugar but in 2017 as Soto made
an unexpected return to film with
Dominican boxing drama Samba when Bruna
tempte confirmed that he was going to be
appearing in Captain Marvel he could
barely contain his excitement the actor
was quite clearly fired up for his
Marvel debut but what does his character
have to offer
well he's fairly minor you can count
brunch as total comics appearances on
one hand though he belongs to a small
group of Marvel characters who have been
able to destroy one of Captain America's
shields in battle so he's no pushover if
you've ever watched him turn the last
Kingdom your know that the big Norwegian
is already well-versed in battle
sequences he's best known for playing
bearded warlord uber and historical
fiction series for which he trained an
ancient Viking martial arts temper has
also been seen in Sky Atlantic's
fortitude and sports biopic Eddie the
Eagle marvel fans will no doubt
recognize Djimon Honsou from a
supporting role in 2014's guardians of
Galaxy he plays the MCU incarnation of
Korra back
also known as Korra the pursuer in the
comics he was a cyber geneticist charge
of engineering cybernetic warriors for
the Kree military he wound up using the
tech he invented on himself gaining
powers on the process
han-soo made his breakthrough in Steven
Spielberg's Amistad but he's perhaps
best known for his turn as Jabba and
Ridley Scott's gladiator providing a
foil for leading man Russell Crowe the
Benham born actor went on to work with
some of the industry's biggest names
including Angelina Jolie and Lara Croft
Tomb Raider the Cradle of Life Leonardo
DiCaprio and blood diamonds and Keanu
Reeves in Constantine what many people
don't know is that he actually beat
chadwick boseman to the part of King to
chala Honsou voice of a condon leader
and BET's six-part animated black
panther series when he spoke to slash
film as of February 2019 presser Han soo
revealed that Captain Marvel isn't
closely connected to guardians of the
galaxy saying this is a completely
separate story standalone story nothing
to do with guardians other than the fact
that some of those characters
interrupted each other later speaking of
some of those characters another Dead
guardians of the galaxy character pops
up in the 90s at Captain Marvel is
crazier to Ronan the accuser played by
Lee pace are you doing I'm distracting
you big turd blossom
according to pace we're going to see a
slightly more chilled out version of
Ronan the actor explained this isn't the
same Ronan that we knew in guardians of
the galaxy this is before he's become a
fundamentalist about the Kree way of
living but he's still true Crais the
opportunity to reprise her role of Ronan
was welcomed by pace who thoroughly
enjoyed working on guardians
he told IGN I loved the film I found the
character very very interesting this
kind of charismatic space terrorist but
most actors space terrorists would be
the weirdest role on their resume by
some distance but pace was both a
vampire and an elf before he was a Kree
the actor played Garrett in the final
instalment of the Twilight franchise and
appeared in every film in Peter
Jackson's Hobbit trilogy as strand well
the elven king of the woodland realm
why did you do that was to set him free
did the identity of Jude Law's character
was one of the biggest mysteries
surrounding Captain Marvel drawing US
production the studio seemingly
confirmed that the British actor was
playing Marvel the original Captain
Marvel in the comics in December 2018
but a few months later it was revealed
that law was actually playing young rug
he had to wear colored contact lenses to
play the Kree commander but most film
fans will still have recognized law from
as many Hollywood roles over the years
he came to the attention of
international audiences at the turn of
millennium that when he starred
alongside Matt Damon and a number of
other big names and the talented mr.
Ripley lor went on to work with many of
the industry's top directors and in 2018
he took on the iconic role of Albus
Dumbledore in fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald playing a younger
version of the future Hogwarts
headmaster in a psso Captain Marvel was
the most physically demanding role that
lore has taken in a long while
when slash film asked him how many
action sequences he had in the movie the
actor confirmed that there were three in
total saying
one of them's been really fun which he
already shot there are some other
fantastic battle sequences brie Larson
officially arrived in the hollywood a
list of 2015's room putting in an
oscar-winning performance as a woman
held captive for seven years everyone
knew her name after the academy names
are Best Actress but people already knew
her face before a star-making Turner's
joy Newsom Larson was becoming one of
those act
that you're sure you've seen somewhere
before even if you can't put your finger
on it
after some scene-stealing roles and
comedy hits like Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world and the reboot of 21 Jump Street
she made waves on the indie scene with a
powerful performance in short term 12
she worked with Mark Wahlberg and The
Gambler and supported Amy Schumer in
trainwreck but as soon as she laid her
hands on that coveted statuettes bigger
offers started to come her way after
room Larson booked the co-lead in Kong
Skull Island playing an anti-war
photojournalist in Kangxi got to work
with Marvel veteran Samuel Jackson who
plays a major role in Captain Marvel
Larson also cast Jackson in a feature
directorial debut unicorn store after
the years of collaborating Jackson has
confirmed that Larson's fitness regimen
for Skull Island was nowhere near as
strenuous as what she's been doing to
get in shape for her big MCU debut
Jackson told Collider the girl that I
did Kong and unicorn store with is not
this person
she's like 5% body fat now the supremely
talented Ben Mendelsohn seemed to appear
out of nowhere but the Australian actor
has quietly been putting in outstanding
performances for years now he came to
the attention of international audiences
with a starring role in the Aussie drama
Animal Kingdom a Melbourne's set crime
flick that wild critics are whirled over
the movie was his Hollywood calling card
and in recent years the character actor
has become Tinseltown's new go-to
villain you're probably recognized
Mendelsohn from his turn as Imperial
military director Orson cranek in 2016 s
rogue one a Star Wars story or perhaps
you've seen him in 2018 s ready player
one he played a Nolan Sorento CEO of the
shady company seeking full control over
the movies virtual reality haven the
Oasis he's gained a reputation as
something of a chameleon a description
that just happens to fit as Captain
Marvel character perfectly the Emmy
winner plays shape-shifting villain
Talos in the 21st MCU movie Mendelson
explained a little about the scrolls and
typical comical fashion when he spoke to
reporters drawing herself visits space
pigs you know what I mean like tough
tough big zoo you know big tough Scrolls
Captain Marvel is undoubtedly the
biggest gig of leshawna Lynch's career
to date but the English actress isn't
exactly a newcomer if you watch a lot of
British TV there's a good chance you
Sene Lynch before he appeared in
everything from police procedurals and
crime dramas to murder mysteries and
adventure fantasies or earning her
stripes in the UK in 2016 her hard work
was rewarded when she won the lead role
in ABC's still star-crossed the show is
a sequel to Romeo and Juliet's taking
place after the events of Shakespeare's
tragedy sadly for Lynch it wasn't
well-received still star-crossed
received middling reviews and the
ratings were not good
ABC shifted the show from its prime time
slot and later cancelled it altogether
scrapping a planned a second season
Lynch was given the chance to bounce
back with Captain Marvel in which she
plays Carol Danvers Air Force Buddy
Maria Rambo she was a minor character on
the comics but the MCU version will be
far more important to the titular hero
if you don't recognize samuel l.jackson
you must have avoided movies your entire
life from cult classics to temple
blockbusters Jackson has been around the
block more than a few times
becoming Hollywood's most bankable star
in the process his face is one that the
majority of Americans would know in an
instance but his physical appearance in
Captain Marvel is likely to confuse
anyone unfamiliar with the setting of
the movie of course since Captain Marvel
is set in the 1990s Jackson has been d-h
a few decades but a special-effects
Wizards at Lola VFX it's a technique
that Marvel has been experimenting with
in recent years but Captain Marvel is
the first time has been used for the
entirety of a movie Jackson gets a
technique is full approval on his
official Instagram posting a photo of
himself as a young Nick Fury along with
the caption wow this Marvel D aging
thing is doper than I thought the 90s
setting means fans will get to see the
shield boss - his famous eyepatch though
judging from some of Jackson's recent
comments he'll be down to one eye again
by the time the credits roll how did
fury even see these he turns sounds
exhausting Clark Craig's Phil Coulson is
a rookie agent to join the time Captain
Marvel asserts
speaking to den of geek Greg revealed
that the shield Stewart will be a total
newbie when he meets Carol Danvers
saying he's a bit of a new guy in shield
he's a lot younger it's the earliest we
have seen him so when he says that mr.
stark this isn't my first rodeo in iron
man this is maybe the rodeo is talking
about Greg managed to book minor movie
parts throughout the 90s later finding a
home on TV after landing one-off parts
and sex in the city and other shows
Greg joined the cast of The West Wing
sporadically appearing as FBI Special
Agent Michael Casper between 2001 and
2004 in 2008 he directed and acted in
choke an adaptation of Chuck Palin X
book of the same name
ancient all-knowing and a big-screen
floating head the supreme intelligence
as a collection of the smartest cream
Minds
merged over a million years in the past
to create the ultimate weapon to defeat
the squirrels who better to step into
that role than acclaimed actress Annette
Bening Bening has been acting steadily
since the late 80s appearing in
everything from American Beauty to Tim
Burton's cult classic comedy Mars
Attacks more recently she was nominated
for an Oscar for her leading role and
the kids are all rights fans got a
glimpse of Bening as the ancient
Megamind in a recent Captain Marvel
trailer though there are some
differences in her appearance she has a
body for one and it's clear that this
acting powerhouse is a good fit for the
role but even the supreme intelligence
needs a little help from time to time
and Benning had to turn to an unlikely
source to explain some of the more
convoluted aspects of Captain Marvel to
her kids who I then told the story to
and asked them to please explain to me
what the hell was going on check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]